malgré son calme apparent la rivière
bidassoa est une faucheuse de migrants
situé à la frontière franco espagnole
elle constitue la principale menace pour
les milliers de candidats à l'exil qui
tentent de gagner le territoire français
depuis le début de l'année trois d'entre
eux si son loyer au total ce sont six
migrants qui ont perdu la vie en six
mois mais malgré les risques la plupart
de ces jeunes venus d'afrique sub
saharienne assure ne pas avoir peur non
non tout risqué on à risquer la vie
passant par la méditerranée
ya plus de risques enfin j'en à tout
risquer en attendant d'atteindre leurs
objectifs ils sont nombreux à se
rassembler tous les matins sur la place
de la mairie d'irun ils y sont prises en
charge par les bénévoles de cette
association basque ces militants leur
prodigue des conseils et les oriente
vers les centres de la croix-rouge pour
leur porte parole la politique d'accueil
de l'union européenne n'est pas
acceptable elle fait pas ce qu'elle
devait faire c'est d'accueillir les
personnes qui essayaient de chercher une
meilleure vie et larsson il y avait
beaucoup d'interrogations par laquelle
ils ont quitté le pays et arif et jia
chez nous pour tenter de mieux réguler
cet afflux migratoire emmanuel macron a
annoncé un doublement des forces pour
contrôler l'ensemble des frontières
françaises mais pour les associations
d'aidé aux migrants les pouvoirs publics
doivent surtout faire plus pour éviter
de nouveaux morts
sollicité par rt france pour s'exprimer
sur cette demande les autorités
françaises n'ont pas donné suite